in this video we'll talk about
hypertrophy
hypertrophy means increase in the size
of cells which lead to an increase in
the size of affected organ
simply we can understand hypertrophy as
an increase in organ size such as
increase in the size of our muscles
and you must have gone to gene and
increased your bicep size this is an
example of hypertrophy
the hypertrophic organ has no new cells
and it's really important to understand
just that the existing cells are bigger
and stronger that means if this is your
muscle after hypertrophy there is no net
increase in the muscle cells
but there is an overall increase in the
size of the existing muscle cells
hypertrophy can be two types
a physiological hypertrophy and a
pathological hypertrophy
the normal physiological hypertrophy
is okay and it happens due to stress or
increased work demand
and the example is an increase in your
size of your biceps when you do more
physical work or when you do gym
and an example of pathologic hypertrophy
is left ventricular hypertrophy due to
hypertension the wall of the left
ventricle of our heart becomes thick
and there is a hypertrophy in the
cardiomyocytes
this leads to several problems
now let's talk about what are the
factors that can cause hypertrophy so
obviously let the physiological factors
that can cause physiological hypertrophy
is increasing functional demand that
means simply you are
you are like increasing your load in the
gym or you are lifting up more heavy
stuff
also if you are stimulated by several
hormones for example growth hormones
steroid hormones
then there could be hypertrophy as well
anyway in sports there is a malpractice
of
injecting specific hormones to achieve
hypertrophy
then there could be induction by getting
growth factor or by ingesting growth
factor agonists
so all these things can lead to increase
in size of a particular organ in this
case the muscle and possibly lead to
hypertrophy
now there are many chemical and
mechanical signals that can induce the
hypertrophy
chemical signal involves
insulin-like growth factor so in general
many growth factors lead to this kind of
hypertrophy response and insulin growth
like growth factor is one of the key
player in this process
myostatin
androgens
osteocalcin all of these falls under
chemical signals which can induce
hypertrophy apart from the chemical
signals there could be mechanical
signals such as mechanical stretch
straining the muscles which can be
sensed by several integrin receptors
and all of these things signals the
muscle cells
to produce more muscle proteins and get
bigger in the size
simply there are there is an increase in
myofibril synthesis
all these phenomena lead to an increase
in muscular size or muscular hype and
lead to muscular hypertrophy
the massive physiological growth of the
uterus during pregnancy is another
example
in that case
the smooth muscles are
getting hypertrophied by the hormones
such as estrogen so the estrogen
receptors are present in the uterine
smooth muscles and upon
pregnancy
this estrogenic hormone action can lead
to hypertrophy in these muscles
now let's talk about pathologic
hypertrophy
example of pathologic hypertrophy is the
left ventricular hypertrophy
in this case
the heart muscle or the cardiomyocyte
gets bigger in the size as it get bigger
in the size there is less cavity in the
left ventricle that means it can
pump or it can hold less amount of blood
which is bad for the body
the mechanisms that can lead to
the cardiac hypertrophy involves growth
factor like igf-1 which is pretty common
for muscles or any kind of muscles
several agonists involves
alpha adrenergic hormones angiotensins
which are related to blood pressure as
well
also mechanosensors are present in the
heart muscle
which can sense increased hemodynamic
load and that leads to a hypertrophy
all these things lead to production of
bunch of transcription factors such as
meph2 gutta-4 in fat and these thing can
evoke several biological responses such
as synthesis of contractile proteins
induction of uh specific embryonic genes
such as alpha actin
a f etc
one such response is replacing the
alpha isoform of myosin heavy chain with
the beta isoform
and this particular isoform has a slower
more energetically
economical contraction so obviously
these kind of changes are underlying the
cardiac hypertrophy so in this video we
talked about
what is hypertrophy we learned that
hypertrophy is increasing the size of
cells which lead to an increase in the
overall organ size
there is no new cells but existing cells
are getting bigger hypertrophy can be
pathologic or physiologic we looked at
the examples of pathologic and
physiologic hypertrophy
so if you want more nodes and flash
cards you can visit my facebook page
you can go to my instagram page there is
daily interactive quiz and also these
kind of notes
all the links are provided in the
description
you can support my channel using patreon
beam upi app or you can
pay me by the super thanks option which
is present in the bottom right corner of
any video you can contribute using paytm
paypal or any other upi app
if you wish to connect with me all my
social media handles are provided in the
description you can find me by this
particular name also support the nerd
medic channel you can follow the nerd
medic channel and all the links of
nerdmedic channel are also provided in
the description feel free to connect see
you in the next video don't forget to
comment